the west is clear it wants to stop
dependency on russian oil but actually
doing so is more complicated european
countries have been asking canada for
help what we can do in the immediate
term is very limited just because we
didn't invest much since 2014 in the
canadian industry thursday canada
announced it can increase oil and gas
production by the end of 2022 up to 200
000 barrels of oil a day and up to 100
000 equivalent barrels of natural gas we
recognize that replacing russian oil and
gas in the short term
is going to be important canada can play
perhaps a modest role in that
but
our commitment to reaching net
neutrality by 2050 to hitting
our climate commitments by 2030
remains as firm as ever
modest in the face of russia which
produces 10 million barrels a day
canada's 300 thousand would flow through
existing pipelines down to the u.s gulf
coast the natural resources minister
says some may be used by the u.s to
offset russia the rest will be shipped
to the international market mainly
europe the government stresses this
won't impact canada's climate goals
environmentalists disagree those two
things cannot exist at the same time we
cannot
increase our oil and gas production
while also meeting our climate goals in
the long term they can start now but
they should have thought of this seven
years ago conservatives blame a lack of
liberal investment in the sector now we
need output now we need workers and we
don't have either because of their
actions we are paying the price while
the u.s and allies discuss the
possibility of a further release of oil
from storage to help calm markets with
respect to
the emergency stockpile these are
ongoing discussions and all those tools
are certainly on the table while
increasing production to help europe is
the immediate goal canada and allies are
firm that a transition to clean energy
and renewables are the medium and
long-term goals the liberals trying to
convince people they can do both abigail
beeman global news ottawa